Wow, dude. Did you just eat that for real? You know what?
What's up guys welcome back. I'm here with another giant of a man, Mr. Logan Paul!
Logan [oh] that is me. What is up? Yo this guy's crazy, bro! So, today we got the world's largest gummy worm
We're bringing back liquid nitrogen, and we have a blowtorch what's going on what I mean, this is it. This is literally
What's going on right now? This is the world's largest gummy worm that's what they say is that a fact let's check it out
Okay, so it's definitely big
I don't know if it's the world's largest
But like it's a commendable side you know considering they tell these things in bulk
I imagine there's multiple largest yeah, gummy worms
But this is one of the one of the world's largest gummy worms so to start off
We're gonna start off small. We got this bag of gummy worms here in the mood for gum where I actually am okay
I want to eat them. We're going to bust those out
I got a little container here that we're gonna play around with as well, and then we're going to move up
We're just going to answer the question what happens if you blow torch the world's largest gummy worm and drip it into liquid nitrogen
This is going to be sick. We're using a styrofoam container here styrofoam
Have some pretty good insulating properties, and we don't want to wreck your table however. We did go out
We took your ramp to your love stacks
Okay, so we've got  that kind of the base to protect everything. It's true
And we got this huge 35 layer dewar of liquid nitrogen, and we need to transfer into this this is no joke
This is no joke bro. Like I'm a big [bot]. [I] work out and this is every
yeah, you yeah, yeah, [just]
[rip] this thing open. I'll do it get down to that
Oh [what] [I'm] going to do is smell it for me smell it yeah smell it for me
[how's] [off-duty] one bite? I do want to my lodge for this dig in savage?
This is built boob strikes around. I I'll see you later and a half always go okay. Now. I'm just kidding
I wouldn't do that to you bro. Let's go ahead and grab the doer of liquid nitrogen. Let's fill up the styrofoam
Are you saying doer [I'm] saying doer yes like a sewer?
Bew
Ar you are to learn more and more every day because it's basically just a glorified thermos which we have one of those [well]
We're going to load this thing up with liquid nitrogen
We're going to basically create it with the nitrogen bath
Okay, fire up the [blowtorch] and figure out where to go from there alright pretty much it alright, Mr.. Logan Paul
I'll go do the honors. Yeah, oh
oh
There we go. Yeah
very nice
Very nice the good work out g on the burn you have a lumpy on the burn. That's good. Yeah, you'd
That right there my friends is a lot of liquid nitrogen. Yeah, it's like a hundred bucks
What happens when you put a hundred dollar bill in a hundred dollars worth of Liquid nitrogen?
It floats for a second and then any things I do a lot of you just what [happen]?
Oh wow cold hard cats literally cold hard cash
So we just figured [out] the coolest trick. You know how this nitrogen vapor rest on the top
It will react to sound check it out
What you trying to [cuz] I don't got it was pretty cool. I would go to admit that was a dumb [thing]
Okay, so liquid nitrogen has been transferred we have our bag of gummy bears who's going to take this little glass
We're going to dip it in there grab a little nitrogen in the glass first of all at risk of breaking it Keith. Yeah
And I think we're gonna start adjusting this first, okay? I'm open up
Look at the way that it jumped, whoa
That's sick. It's a fireworks show call me Katie bear
What is it the fourth of July is the snow amazing you know oh yeah? I'm like a catholic. You know be cool
Yeah, let's go ahead and drop one in let's just see how quickly it freezes up so first one's been dropped
Let's give it. [just] like [10] seconds. It doesn't need a lot [of] time, right?
Now if you're brave enough [its] reach in there scoop it out like sorry, babe
I'm a Maverick not very fit. Nope wow check it out check it out. It's even cracked down the bottom right
This is this was even crash
That was a gummy worm and it's frozen solid was that 10 seconds. Yeah, easy. Yeah, that could be your finger
I was little bit nervous about you. Having your finger in there that long
[oh] really. Well do did you just eat that for real you know what?
Okay, cool, right, it's so dense
I've always been nervous about eating something like that was it like gumming up on your teeth and [layer] on the enamel
This is good crazy. All right. Let's start. We go open a business [logan's] just brought in our quality control specialist
Yeah, his name is Colin. He was exactly what it's doing. They're going to see what he thinks of them over here
Let's [-] Come look at clot we think
We think [we] can [lovely] [we'll] bring a little more love
Okay, you can hear them cracking popping
It's really interesting
They've actually like self-sabotage and broken themselves in the little pizza since logan's tried one of these I guess you guys I'm obligated
It's the literature into legitimately hard candy. Yeah, it's go, right
That's a boy right there
Yeah
so
Okay, cool. That's good. Oh
Look at the way that that [just] flattened down once the air hit the cold it looks really cool
Are you feeling strong? Yeah? I feel strong, but I think and I [want] to see you take them to snap an apple
I want to do that. Oh
a like break down the spine
Hmm
Whoa and still gummy on the inside yo hard on the outside stuff and squishy on the inside. Yo, this is crazy
There it is
Buggy [all] right that's for you. Thanks, man. I appreciate that please enjoy responsibly and I'm going to give Mr.. Logan the blowtorch here
Cool press the yellow button to activate
And I think we're just going [to] warm this up until it gets syrupy enough to drip straight down there, okay, okay?
Whoa, you think Maverick? I believe so bro
Really [you] think this is going to happen okay toasted toasted, bro
Toasty Toasty brew [oh], it's burning look look
It's like creme Brulee. It literally smells like it
oh
Wow
My gloves are absolutely erected like this stuff down here is really great
Well look at it. Look at [it]. You know like marshmallows when you put them in a fire. Oh
It's just shit. Oh what our gummy [worm] just shed look at that. Yo the skin just came off look at that
We called that twice-baked where I grew up because you can bake it once and then you bake it twice
like
Bubbles instantly on contact [oh] good night blows Bob. Come [boop] there we go
It's like our prince rupert gummy. Drop. What if we can keep that strand going like can it just be one continuous long gummy stream?
I
Got so while we got this stuff cooking up here in the liquid-nitrogen. We're going to throw this in the microwave and melt it down
Here we go
What would you say How long? Three minutes?
Okay, cool
Yo, this is go. Look good. [oh] wow it's cool. Right? It's multicolored. I thought it was burnt, but that's the blue side yeah
So we're gonna. Do now is hold it up close to the ceiling
We're going to drop it [down] and maybe even jiggle it. So we want to get this kind of you got this bro
I'm gonna mess up your youtube video. I don't want to do that like you
What's gonna happen don't miss Gomez come insert a little bit lower, and I'll work my way up because this is a little sketchy
Okay
schedule five of the love doing oh
oh
It's like [you're] pooping. It's like poops little poop
whoa
It's raining melted gummy worms
Look at the way the colors are splitting you set the red and the blue are still ready together there
It actually looks really neat you know there's a lot of stuff going down right now
Like here isn't going [down]. This is dripping is landing. I got liquid nitrogen literally running all [over] my apartment
[what] is happening? How is it happening?
Where did you come from?
[we're] never met before
This is crazy. Thanks for letting me come in destroy your house, bro. I'm into it
You chose the right half to destroy my boy all right. I'm going to call that good things are just settled down here
You can actually see down into the pool of nitrogen now. What do you see? It looks like it formed like a little volcano
Island this is really cool. Maybe how volcanoes should be formed out of coming so you can actually feels like intermixed
There's blue red, and it's kind of like really sporadic
Yeah, I'm thinking we reach down there grab that by the [tip] yep pull that whole [eye] for a greater. Good yep, yep
Second [oh] riddle songs are going to make a difference because actually these pizzas have frozen so quickly
They're not joined together, so I'm just going [to] reach in there with a scoop you're going to do it
I think we're just out of it. Yeah here we go
My whole life is built up to this moment. This is a moment. This is why you were born [oh], yeah
Look at that what oh wow looks like rocks dude like granite almost. They're popping like Pop rocks look at that
Look at that. Look like [nerds]. You know that were there. Yeah
I'm popping you know what they look like. It's like dippin dots, bro
Yeah, like a little those little ice cream balls nitrogen discs gummy dots. Which are one yeah, all right bon appetit
I
Got the nose, okay?
Grand Finale Logan is Gonna take the whole bag of gummy worms and dump all at once. It's true. I'm gonna do that
[any] good everywhere. [oh] [never] what yeah?
Bonus experiment someone asked what a blowtorch would do to liquid nitrogen
Doesn't do anything
absolutely nothing yeah, oh
That's pretty yeah
All these are just so brittle as crap
You can literally like rub them between your fingers and [fur] number powder you ever had powdered gummy [worms]
So there you have a guys that's what happens when you take a [blowtorch] to the world's largest gummy worm in a vat of liquid
Nitrogen huge thanks to Logan Paul for helped me out this experiment
You can check him out the link in the description below he posts daily vlogs they easily row with Kong Maverick
We've got a lot of cool things going
Yo, thanks for having me dude. There's so much fun. Hey guys. Thanks to join us for this experiment
We'll be looking for in the next one. Talk to you then
sure
What formerly was known as is depleting its way into being feeding and the cameras off way out here
I need you to get at me. Go get me bro. I got a brother Jake Paul
he's not out of [hope] it's kind of cool, and I got you got a lot of the subscribers [bullying] me and
Sometimes when I rap, but in the true feelings, I really I wish I could pass them in subscribers
But he's really good youtube but I think also I love it, and I'm just having a whole family's doing well
Hey guys, I want to jump back in for just a second to invite you to come follow me on Instagram
I've got a very active page where I post daily pictures and stories of behind the scenes and every day is an adventure
Just take five seconds right now to click the link in the description to come follow me on Instagram at the king of random
Help you there